a transformação transformação a palavra
que eu gosto muito curto não é facebook
é curtir mesma vida porque a
transformação é uma palavra que eu gosto
porque eu sou uma das pessoas e mulheres
no mundo que transforma o mundo de algum
jeito mas antes de o transformar o mundo
eu quis me transformar eu me transformo
eu me olho eu me enxergo para dentro de
muitas vezes a gente fica preocupado com
o que o outro está fazendo o que a gente
paga pra pensar que a gente pode fazer
hoje
deus nos dá 24 horas o que a gente está
fazendo por agente e pelo outro
vamos colocar uma energia boa aqui nesse
lugar pra quem está do teu lado me
rápido gente agora pra nóis pra nossa
gente olha agora foi a energia positiva
bastante agora coloca no teu coração de
novo mais rápido de novo só que essa
quem gosta de dar então a gente vai dar
pra quem está do lado da avôs e estão
demorando porque ele passou do século 20
um gatinho gatinho
então a gente vai levantar nossas mãos e
vamos apenas nos abraçar e ver que ser
humano lindo que somos fez os olhos um
segundo e pense na missão que cada um de
nós tem se sair é só trabalhar trabalha
com amor não está satisfeito ver o teu
dom
no sábado tem o dom que faz a pergunta
de noite onde nós para pensar agora
sentem
quando disse de transformação quando
quis me mudar
eu sempre teve fui muito quieta é tanto
a sair de casa com 15 anos da paraíba e
foi casar foi foi a tal liberdade com 16
anos grávida de 17 fui mãe glória a deus
né ai você sabe
vipcomm rio de janeiro há 11 anos me
trabalhar como empregada doméstica
só que eu sou uma menina muito esperta
muita tempo que está acontecendo é isso
que está faltando na gente a gente
enxergar se olhar se observar de dentro
pra fora e valorizar quem está aqui do
nosso lado
então com a minha ex patroa
a minha foi a maior patrocinadora dos
meus sonhos que hoje eu estou aqui com
vocês e milhares de pessoas pelo mundo
afora em 2011 e vê um curso gente se
liga nessa história em 2011 ver o 11
curso que se chama agência de redes para
o juventude
as jovens de 15 a 29 anos a data limite
porque isso foi em abril agosto fazia 30
o linda e maravilhosa ela vai roliça
mais linda
aí gente
fui pra eu fui desenvolveu o projeto
favela orgânica que esse projeto que
realmente me transformei me transforma é
muito lindo
quando a gente faz uma coisa que
acredita e deus me deu melhor dom de
unir as pessoas através do alimento
estão fazendo orgânico é um projeto que
trabalha com o ciclo da vida e o ciclo
do alimento é a gente devolver a terra
que a terra nos dá é a gente observar o
nosso consumo
o ciclo da vida ea gente entender que
besouro da gostosa somos nós que delícia
de pessoas ou 19 por isso fala se eu sou
regina este ano anda início de pessoas
é isso eu mesmo quero conscientizar de
seu gato então eu me conscientizando e
tem muito mas a seu saber que com um
talo eu posso contar de blocos 1 com
brócolis não possa ser cinco pratos
diferente posso ficar e por exemplo o
tallinn posso fazer uma conserva de talo
de broco as folhas posso fazer uma couve
mineira mas só com limão e alecrim é com
talo que lutaram comer até o talo a
gente pode fazer uma lasanha com o
próprio talo a um estrogonofe
então assim muitas idéias são muito e
assim deus me deu esse dom de olhar os
alimento com carinho porque independente
de seu software dinheiro ou
empreendedora social vocês o empresário
dono diz dom daquilo
a gente precisa se alimentar ea gente
não está se incomodando e nem prestando
atenção e nosso alimento vai acabar ea
maior economia que existe no mundo é o
alimento eo preconceito das casca
eu fui dos o pop gente fiz um banquete
com dois meses quando desenvolveu o
projeto
eu vou falar um pouco do início primeiro
a yosuf quando desenvolvi ele fui
apresentava uma banca avaliadora efeito
legal foi melhor não da minha vida
porque eles é muito complexo não sei o
que ele tá bom tudo bem
chorei abençoado isso foi 30 de agosto
quando foi 24 de setembro o teu projecto
denunciando a minha casa com 140 reais e
nem ela nem mesmo pra começar todo mundo
me ajudou
já começou em comunhão mas nega o jeito
foi seis mães de família que foram
assistir uma aula sendo empregada
doméstica como eu
aí o diploma não valeu foi meu
conhecimento que muitas vezes e dá valor
diploma e quantas diplomas às vezes a
gente agora tem muitos certificado tá
aí está bem mali em muitas vezes a gente
deixa de de fazer mesmo as coisas aí o
legal que elas virão de imediato que ela
esteve a economia dentro de casa eu
tiver autonomia de sair de casa e elas
não saíam de casa aí pra mim foi
fantástico de eagle segunda semana foram
10 a terceira foram 15 a quarta foram 40
até gente do japão fica quieta aceita ou
não
aí com dois mese peça da comunidade da
favela é catar mas não só da família não
disse é o stop também não icann beleza
fiz uma bela de uma mesa como eu
gostaria de ser comida e vista
aí eu disse vai lá pessoal com o menino
quando servi liberar geral tudo levando
quem tinha pra casa do garoto gol
na mesma semana eu fiz um asfalto que
infelizmente as pessoas essa separação
pra mim é tudo é casa tudo é fato teto
céu tudo ao que acontece até grã-fina lá
foram ser tudo assim eu amo pega esse
povo tudo nariz em pé que esses são
ótimos de trabalhar só porque depois
eles têm que descer do salto porque o
alimento é que alimenta
fiquei muito famosa por seis meses no
paraná bbc mundo de na bbc mundo de um
negócio é aproveitar tão paulo mesmo aí
sabe que ele não do belo não levei a e
também fiz a recepção do harrison ford
ele falou diego godín que os autocarros
e melancia
porque só porque ele não queria com
venda do meu filho e viagra natural vás
embora ele foi assim
o governo divulgou que a mulher dele a
dona o brigadeiro de casca de banana
aí foi feito após a recepção de um
príncipe que tem umas sardinhas e quando
me lembro o nome do povo que eu chamo
delícia cheiroso
aí fica mais fácil né lembra ainda de
senão que eu levei fui melhor não gente
com 11 meses eu ganhar o primeiro prémio
de mulheres empreendedoras e comunidades
do brasil te mete com a pessoa
mas isso não foi só o prémio que me
ajudou a levantar o museu o
empreendimento que eu faço que dizem que
é o primeiro totalmente alternativa é
pão paz tinha tudo do aproveitamento
total de um parceria com os produtores
orgânico produtor é com próprias feiras
livres do rio de janeiro e os próprios
comerciantes local da favela mas não
parou por aí porque o que eu achei muito
legal desse prêmio que eu quero passar
para vocês que a gente precisa mudar de
dentro pra fora já mudamos né
agora vou mudar o que está ao nosso
redor então as empresas elas estão se
ligando cara precisa mudar precisa
trabalhar que as pessoas que trabalham
com essa tem que entender que são
parceiros resina ela é top gente saiba
nunca foi para foi pra itália pelo
movimento slow food e terra madre da
palestra para 600 pessoas mais chefe do
montada lá eu estava lá estava mais
conhecida do que pau de galinheiro
quando eu volto deixem de ser empregada
doméstica na época por que você viaja
mas europa volta o povo que respeita
tudo bem está ótimo que respeito mas é
do começo então eu quero me respeitar
aí a gente foi vários lei fim de cada
uma das 80 pessoas mais influentes
sustentabilidade no mundo ano eu fui a
primeira mulher e segunda brasileira da
aula é cozinhar na faculdade sem esses
gastronômica na itália nunca entrei numa
faculdade fui logo após europa e hoje em
dia meu bem eu dou aula em faculdade com
a doutorado me achar que eu nem sei nem
sabe o que eles aguentem um pouquinho é
nutricionista agrônomo porque é
nutricionista também minhas lindas pelo
amor de deus vamos cozinhar ea gente
precisa saber de onde vêm os nossos
alimentos
a gente precisa plantar porque o chef de
cozinha perdoe
ele precisa se orientar para jesus
não só ele
nós porque eles estão tão preocupado com
as estrelas do show que eles estão
fazendo
estão esquecendo que quem dá ele querer
ser estrela o show são os alimentos e os
produtores e as terra eles não estão nem
aí
por isso que eu digo não quero ser
estrelas ou uma constelação
antes da gente se valorizar
valorizamos nossa vida que a gente só
tem uma
em qualquer lugar que vocês forem não
deixa é igual ao que já nem sei qual
cause o negócio é causa seja aonde for
língua qualquer coisa por exemplo na
itália não sabia nada fique todo mundo
fazer isso na nem paris também é a mesma
coisa
e aonde não foi isso que a gente precisa
se sentir a gente precisa se valorizar
a gente precisa mudar e vai mudar quando
a gente quiser
se a gente quiser uma vida melhor não
faça meu bem e espero fazer não e quando
alguém te criticar faça para detectar
mesmo continuar fazendo porque é a única
pessoa que vai construir que vai uma
coisa que eu gosto muito de falar tudo
que plantamos colhemos e nessa então vão
atrás dos produtores que plantam para
vocês por favor tá não fica falando que
é orgânico é claro que só quer fazer
lynch mas não orgânico é assim é
acessível quando a gente tem a nossa
munda da cadeira e vai atrás dele quando
a gente tá em contato com o produtor e
ver o carinho que ele tem com a gente
isso muda eo alimenta da unir não
passará então aproveita a vida até o
talo é tão interessante que eu amei é
que não é só no brasil mas no mundo a
mudança está acontecendo ea digital se
ligue se acordem se valorize
existe o evento que há 20 anos existe na
itália de mulheres do mundo todo pela
primeira vez a brasileira estava lá
regina celi representam a mulherada
e foi convidada para ser embaixadora do
desenvolvimento global se médico a
pessoa
isso teve já várias coisas primeiras
segunda 10 esse time não me interessa em
título só quer uma coisa que deus me dê
cada vez mais humildade ea linguagem de
vocês que é do povo para de negócio
technos o que é necessário em algumas
coisas mas vamos falar com o coração
vamos agir
aproveito até o talo ea vida que vocês
têm é hoje obrigada